yesterday we had a story on the David
Pakman show about a source of mine
telling me that 15 Trump electors have
formed a coalition not to vote for
Donald Trump and that they are quietly
lobbying other Trump electors to do the
same and of course I expressed that this
was a number that would be far short if
true of the 37 that would need to flip
to deny Donald Trump the presidency
not to mention that 38 would need to go
towards Hillary Clinton to give her the
270 270 votes she would need things have
gotten very very interesting over the
last 24 hours number one that story was
picked up by half a dozen or so news
outlets associates co-hosts of Infowars
the Alex Jones Show have also talked
about it not in the most positive light
but not particularly negative either
just sort of saying if true this points
out the desperation of the Democratic
Party on Twitter many users asking
Donald Trump
Kellyanne Conway Reince Priebus for some
kind of comment or reaction to this
story but really the most interesting
part of this and this is just it this is
big it's taking a life of its own and I
had no choice but to immediately tell
you what I've learned over the last 24
hours
I've learned today I spoke to many
people many people wanted to get in
touch with me over the last 24 hours and
have spoken with many many people over
the last 24 hours
the most interesting conversations were
to with individuals who told me that
they were of the impression that there
were some Trump electors who were
planning not to vote for Donald Trump in
a completely uncoordinated way and that
the number to their knowledge that the
people they were aware of is not
anywhere close to 15 but then I spoke to
a longtime Democratic operative who in
no uncertain terms told me that they
believe
I want to speak as carefully as possible
to not overstate nor understate what
they said they believe based on direct
contacts that they have been speaking
with that there is a group of Trump
electors not necessarily 15 but not far
from 15 that is indeed planning to not
vote for Donald Trump but have decided
understandably considering the death
threats against electors that we've
heard alleged over the last 24 hours and
four sort of obvious reasons have not
decided to go forward and make that
public at this time now here's the real
question and this this is where it
starts to get really crazy at minimum
what we've heard is that the 15 number
that my source told me which I reported
to you yesterday may be slightly higher
than what is being corroborated by this
Democratic operative but that it is
close that right that's possibility one
that it's not 15 but that in talking
about the same general group of electors
maybe it's 9 10 11 or 12 but there's
another possibility and this is what is
being sort of attempted to be sorted out
right now which is are we talking about
two totally separate groups here is
there the group of 15 that I was told
about yesterday and I reported to you in
short order in addition to another group
that could make up 9 to 12 and of course
that is that is a drastically different
scenario the 15 I talked about yesterday
is interesting in its own right if we
are indeed talking about two separate
groups here and it appears that that may
be the case I think you can obviously
understand why this drastically changes
the situation we're talking about
everybody is very skittish right now and
I'm continuing to talk to people and we
will see what else comes of this and and
of course if I learn anything else about
this even if it's over the weekend I
will immediately report on this and talk
about it and in just a few minutes I'm
going to be starting a Facebook live
event where I'm going to be going into
more detail about this so please join me
there facebook.com
slash david pakman show and and I will
sort of reiterate the story take
questions etc